it's rich its creamy it's honestly to
die for hi I'm Betsy I'm a tasty
producer and today I'm going to show you
how to make my grandmother's seafood
casserole first we're gonna take a bread
loaf and tear it into roughly cube sized
pieces they don't have to be perfect and
we're going to lightly toast them in the
oven
then we'll put them in a food processor
and pulse them until they're finely
ground I personally like to have a few
chunks for some extra crunch but you
should have about 4 cups total when it's
all said and done a lot of people have
different names for their grandparents I
called my grandmother gammy and she's
someone who is so near and dear to my
heart she was known in our family as the
casserole Queen she loved hosting dinner
parties and this dish especially was
always a hit with her guests my aunt
actually mailed me my Gammy's
handwritten recipe which is pretty cool
according to my grandfather the recipe
is probably 70 years old you'll bring
the wine back to a boil and add the
scallops when the scallop has become
opaque meaning they're no longer
transparent you'll know they're done
some of my favorite memories of my gammy
involve food I think that's one of the
reasons why I love to cook I think she
kind of helped spark my curiosity for it
when my gammy moved to Delaware from
North Carolina after she married my
granddad she didn't know anyone with
three kids she actually went back to
college at night to get her degree in
special ed which was a fairly new field
of study in the 60s and then she became
a special education teacher she actually
never lost her southern accent either
even though she lived in Delaware for
like 70 years I'm honestly not really
surprised at her ability to connect with
people and I don't think it really
surprised anyone who met her she was
definitely a social butterfly maybe
that's how I've become a little more
outgoing even though she's no longer
with us here on earth being able to cook
her own recipes definitely makes me stay
connected to her
I hope she'd be proud to see how far my
culinary skills have come
Oh God uh now I'm getting all emotional
after you butter the casserole dish
you'll scatter some artichokes in an
even layer on the bottom and then top
them off with the seafood mixture so my
gammy liked to add shrimp scallops and
crab meat to the casserole but you can
get creative with your own seafood
combinations or mix-ins maybe you want
to add some lobster maybe you want to
add some salmon for me crabmeat is a
must as someone from Delaware we love
our crabs especially blue crabs pour the
sauce all over yeah baby and then top
with the breadcrumb mixture and that
flavor just takes me back to all the
summers I spent at the beach with my
family and friends who I could really go
for a crab cake right now according to
the notes gammy left with her
handwritten recipe you just need a light
salad with it it'll help balance out the
heaviness from the casserole I also like
to top it off with some chives and then
serve it with a couple women wedges for
a little extra flavor I'm so proud to be
the granddaughter of such a loving and
welcoming woman I can't wait to continue
her legacy and pass down her recipes to
the future generations in my family oh
yes
[Music]
[Music]